literally just on with a founder before
we got on to tape this episode uh and it
was a private call about investment and
they had closed around in the
nine figure range 100 million or so wow
um before they had launched and one of
these big you know uh top-tier um you
know hedge fund type people coming down
and playing was offering them a series b
at 3x
before they launched yeah and i was like
how do you not take that as a founder
but what's the diligence there because
the product's not even launched so
really interesting stuff going on
let's talk about how we can reduce risk
in the venture community
uh what do you advise uh you know
sometimes like i said there's this
tension around diligence and maybe some
people are relying on the previous
person's diligence
that seems a little risky to me it's
definitely risky i mean every vc fund
should be doing their diligence
and what we do see when they when
there's enough time
they'll often hire like a you know big
four accounting firm to actually get in
there and interface with us when we're
kind of representing the company that's
actually having the diligence done on us
so they're doing operational accounting
diligence they're doing financial
projections diligence and they're doing
tax diligence all three of those are
actually pretty important and we can get
into some of the we you know the things
that founders should be aware of like
the the traps that you kind of talked
about whether they're doing it
tell us about some of those traps that a
founder might find themselves in where
all of a sudden there's a blocker
there's a red flag and they didn't
anticipate it because i didn't actually
i mean i get projections i i get the
current accounting i actually didn't
even think about like looking at the tax
stuff so explain to me what are some of
the blockers that you've seen happen
when people are trying to close around
and all of a sudden something gets
discovered yeah the classic is like you
actually mentioned one of them at the
beginning
over inflating your revenue so just a
couple quick things like sometimes
especially if they're on cash
they will you know send out invoice
count out as revenue and then they'll
actually count the cash they collected
as revenue which is like a very simple
double counting yeah the other thing
which people do is they
they
they basically collect like a 200 000
deal up front and then they annualize
that into their arr
when that's just a one-time payment
right that's not reoccurring revenue
right that is the biggest thing like you
probably have a me you have a coffee
meeting with somebody ask them what
their mrr arr is and if they're over
inflating that you're you don't know
they've over inflated it you're getting
excited you're getting ready to issue a
term sheet due the diligence meanwhile
they the the emperor has no clothes
right and they have to go they're not
gonna be able to go find just another
one of those deals to replace it every
month it's gonna be a problem for them
so
and revenue is for for better or worse
is a very strong signal for startups and
so like
that's the thing that everyone's going
to focus on there's i mean it's for
better generally like when we as
investors you know see revenue we say
hey that's hard to fake right but there
are things on the margin like we're
talking about oh you sent an invoice you
booked it but you didn't actually come
in oh you sold them a year but it
doesn't have in the contract that their
credit card gets hit us you know on
january 1st again so you said it was
reoccurring we give you the benefit for
reoccurring over 20 30 times revenue
when we shouldn't give you that right we
should give you two or three times that
revenue um
what about uh actual fraud like you get
to see things obviously i can't ask you
to talk about specific situations
without trying to kill anybody here
or get them investigated but broad
strokes you know give us a composite of
bad behavior seen over the the years
yeah the the the biggest one that comes
to mind is when companies are faking
their bank statements and so
oh totally that is there was like a four
billion dollar fraud in germany and we
actually had a company last year
that kind of like that signed up with us
and we hadn't gotten them on board yet
hadn't started work yet
and
one of their investors kind of was like
hey you need to really check this thing
out because i think some weird stuff's
happening here and before we could
actually like really dig in the sec
took action and it turned out
the founder had been downloading the
bank statements
using adobe to
manipulate the numbers and showing like
millions of dollars in the bank when
really there's thousands of dollars in
the bank what is the best practice there
then as an accounting firm or as a
diligence firm yeah to make sure that's
not happening because people may not
want to give you their login but do some
of these banks provide like a login
where you can't do anything but it's
view only or do you log in over their
shoulder and like have them pull up the
bank statement and on a computer or on a
shared screen sharing and zoom or
something it's the view only access
which we get for every single client
because we want to be able to pull that
down ourselves so that we can validate
it instead of the oh because like jason
you may hear like the oh i'll send you
those bank statements i don't i don't
really want to give anyone access or for
whatever bad reason and so that's that
point where they could actually
manipulate it and once they manipulate
bank statement you can make quickbooks
look however you want to make it look
like journal entries and things like
that but that's actually the biggest
thing and so just having the only your
account that should download it directly
your accountant should also
reconcile the accounts which means tying
quickbooks
into the bank statement and literally
checking off every transaction you do
that inside of quickbooks easy peasy
yeah but but people sometimes people
think this because they entered
transactions that it's reconciled but
you actually have to tie everything out
and make sure there's not kind of like
hidden transactions that someone kind of
covered up that's also a big big area